my Fulton is not in my show okay um much
thought maybe uh you can watch me play
ball sometime or something high school
musical fans today is a lucky day
because Ashley Tisdale has blessed us
with a tick tock video recreating an
iconic scene I'd rather stick pins in my
eyes well wouldn't it be awfully
uncomfortable evaporate tall person one
more time in full just because it's that
good Bolton is not in my show okay
um much thought maybe um you can watch
me play ball sometime or something I'd
rather stick pins in my eyes
who wouldn't it be awfully uncomfortable
evaporate tall person it's been 14 years
since the og High School Musical first
came out but it's pretty clear that
Ashley still got that sharp a sass
Bolton is not in my show okay um what
just thought maybe you could watch me
play ball sometime or something I'd
rather stick pins in my eyes
who wouldn't it be awfully uncomfortable
evaporate tall person Ashley made the
video to celebrate reaching a million
followers on tick-tock in just two days
but let's be real Ashley is a social
media superstar on nearly every platform
including YouTube where she showed off
her singing chops with her real-life BFF
and High School Musical co-star Vanessa
Hudgens YouTube is so much fun I just
feel like it's such a great way to be a
creator in your own life of like what
you want to put out there and I I know
my fans had been wanting music for so
long and so music sessions was a very
natural fit for my channel but the
triple threat isn't the only hsm star to
take a walk down memory lane in November
Vanessa said Instagram on fire when she
gave us the gift of a slightly tipsy
karaoke version of breaking free
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]